- [Narrator] In this
video we're gonna think
about analog versus digital signals.
And one way to think about the difference
is an analog signal is trying to reproduce
exactly in some type of a signal
what is going on while a
digital signal is converting it,
usually the ones and zeros which
then can be converted back.
So the first thing to realize
is that almost any type of information,
it might be how intense a certain color is
or how bright it is or it
might be a frequency of sound,
all of that can be represented as numbers.
So whether you're trying to transmit
an analog signal or a digital signal
it really is about how do
you communicate numbers
using some type of signal.
And as an example, let's
say that you are trying
to communicate the number 24 to someone.
Well, one way to do it
is as an analog signal.
You could have, as time goes on,
maybe this is some type
of voltage across a wire.
And if you put that voltage
right at what the other person
receiving it could interpret it as 24,
well then you would
transmit it and they might,
if they get this nice clean
signal, see it as a 24.
Now the problem with analog signals
is what happens when
you have interference.
So let's say this is a really long wire
that you're transmitting it over
or you're transmitting
it using radio waves,
and there's a lot of bad weather
or other types of interference.
And so on the receiving end
even though you transmit
something that looks like
this, that is a clear 24,
the other person might
get something like this.
And so this isn't obvious
that is a 24 anymore.
It goes between 20 and 30,
and this could be interpreted as static
or a garbled up message
or just doesn't sound as clean
depending on what the 24
is trying to represent,
or the image isn't as clear,
if this is representing say the lightness
or the brightness of a pixel.
Now the other option is to
convert that 24 into binary.
So 24 can be represented
in binary as 1 1 0 0 0.
Now we have other videos on Khan Academy
that explain how to convert back and forth
between our decimal
system that has 10 digits,
zero through nine, and the binary system,
which has two digits, zero and one.
But in case you're curious,
and you don't have to understand this
to know the difference between
analog and digital signals
and when they might be useful,
this first place is the ones
place just as you're used to.
But instead of this being the tens place,
this is the twos place.
Instead of this being the hundreds place,
this is the forth place.
Instead of this being the thousands place,
this is the eights place.
And instead of that being
the ten thousandths place,
that's the sixteens place.
So one way to think about it,
1 1 0 0 0 means 1/16 and 1/8.
And if you add those
together, you would get 24.
What would that actually
look like as a signal?
Well, it could look something like this.
Where the person interpreting it knows
that over this first time period
whatever voltage you're getting,
that tells you your first digit,
that over the next time, period
whatever voltage you're getting
tells you the second digit,
and so on and so forth.
So this would be 1 1 0 0 0.
Now, why is this useful?
Well, let's think about the situation
where all of a sudden
there's interference again.
Now with the interference,
you could still interpret
this exactly as 1 1 0 0 0.
Remember the person receiving the signal
or the system receiving the signal
is just trying to determine
whether it's getting a one or a zero.
So even though this is being
perturbed right over here,
it's clear that we are at a one.
We know that it would not be a 0.9 or 1.1.
It has to be either one or zero.
So it's clear that over
this part right over here,
you're getting a one,
and then over here you're
getting three zero.
So they would be able to
interpret it as 1 1 0 0 0,
which is once again exactly 24.